bonjour à tous effectivement
enseignants cherchent
droit donc ne partez pas tout de suite
j'en vois qui
je les sorties de secours alors c'est un
petit peu pour ça que je suis ici devant
vous un an pour tout vous expliquer le
doyen de la faculté de droit enfin le
directeur de la faculté de droit est
venu me voir en disant que christophe il
faut absolument que tu fasses cette
conférence ted tedx il m'explique
rapidement j'écoute ya évidemment où je
vais pas le faire et me dit on ne te
perds appâter surcomplémentaire j'ai eu
écoute je vais le faire mais je veux
faire quoi et me dit bacchus et nous les
juristes on souffre d'une mauvaise image
bon tu pourrais essayer de démontrer
fins de faire croire qu'on a deux bras
deux jambes qu'on a un coeur et un peu
d'humour j'ai dit est ce que tu peux me
rappeler le nombre d'heures
complémentaires que j'ai fait cette
année
voilà donc voilà la raison pour laquelle
je suis ici devant vous aujourd'hui
tenté de démontrer que le juriste est un
être humain comme les autres alors parmi
les images qui circulent sur les
juristes il y en a une quand même qui
est récurrente à savoir pour réussir en
droit
l'étudiant doit apprendre le code parker
je suis sûr que cela plupart d'entre
vous ont déjà entendu ça c'est une idée
qui alla qui a la peau dure on va dire
alors le code c'est quoi le code c'est
un recueil de textes de loi au sens
large également de jurisprudence la
jurisprudence et l'ensemble des
décisions qui sont rendus à partir de
l'inta de près de l'interprétation qui
est faite de ces textes donc un code ça
ressemble à ça l'intérieur d'un code ça
ressemble à ça mon image pas très net
vous avez le texte est ensuite les
décisions de jurisprudence qui sont
rendus à partir de l'interprétation qui
est faite autrement dit apprendre le
code parker c'est apprendre ça tout ça
alors première remarque pourquoi faut-il
apprendre le code parker en 1804 il y
avait un code
désormais il y en a 75 donc il faut pas
apprendre le code parker il faut
apprendre les codes parker alors on fait
un petit calcul en prenant pour base de
calcul
une page par jour ce qui permet déjà de
le faire en premier écrémage entre les
étudiants d'origine humaine et ceux qui
viennent d'ailleurs un code contient
environ 3000 pages 1 d'autres en
contient un peu plus un peu moins donc
trois mille pages x 75 code
ça nous donne à peu près de 125 mille
pages une page un jour de 125000 jours à
apprendre ça on ramène ça en nombre
d'années ça fait six ans cette année
donc premier constat on peut le dire les
études de droit sont relativement longue
alors de deux choses l'une soit
effectivement les études de droit sont
réservés à une une espèce venue
d'ailleurs qui aurait pris forme humaine
pour se fondre dans dans son
environnement soit cette idée est une
fausse idée je vous laisse je vous
laisse choisir alors autre autre image
qui est véhiculée sur les juristes voilà
ça c'est vrai nom c'est donc il ya une
erreur cette image contient une erreur
mais je vous laisse la deviner le
connais pas en vrai qu'au récession
bientôt c'est une juriste elle sourit
elle sourit alors évidemment c'est
choquant pourquoi parce que tout le
monde sait que le jury c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement sérieux et qui ne sourit
jamais ce qui nous fait dire ce qui me
permet d'affirmer que c'est un grossier
montage ou que cette personne est une
actrice non l'image de jury ce que l'on
a c'est plutôt ça nous avons c'est la
photo d'un étudiant en droit
particulièrement épanouie on peut le
dire
voire carrément heureux au sens du droit
tout est relatif
voilà alors je ne vous montre montre pas
la photo d'un juriste ans en fin de
carrière pour ne choquer personne
alors pourquoi pourquoi le juriste ne
sourit pas alors plusieurs hypothèses
s'affrontent depuis plusieurs siècles
déjà pour mary potez on n'a pas le temps
de rien on doit se farcir 15 75 corps
dans quelques années vous croyez qu'on
attend de rire croyez qu'on attend de se
raconter des blagues donc le juriste
père le rire il oublie de rire l'heure
j'en vois qui sourit ça n'a aucun sens
pour moi c'est un peu gênant si vous
pouvez arrêter supplie
merci noam hypothèse deuxième hypothèse
le rire étant le propre de l'homme
le juriste n'étant pas humains forcément
le syllogisme est imparable
il ne rit pas troisième hypothèse peut
être que ceux qui prétendent que le
juriste est très sérieux trop sérieux ne
connaissent pas beaucoup du riste je
vous laisse choisir
autre constat c'est plutôt un constat
qui fait que les jurys se sont
considérés comme des êtres à part c'est
le langage juridique langage juridique
avec une terme terminologie particulière
avec des expressions particulières
alors il est vrai que je dois l'avouer
certains termes peuvent surprendre
or nous les juristes on est on est les
seuls à faire la distinction entre
disposer est stipulé en droit des
successions il faut savoir on apprend la
fente endroit pour récupérer de l'argent
on demande la grosse et en droit on peut
se vanter on peut se vanter la grosse et
un passant ont demandé de l'argent en
demandant la grosse ça n'a absolument
rien d'illégal en soient d'accord se
renvoient pas une activité illégale
c'est la copie la copie d'une décision
de justice
en droit on peut se vanter d'être les
seuls à utiliser un mot qui commence par
nuno nonobstant et en comprendre le sens
aussi on aime bien également les
locutions latines on aime bien usées
utilisées abuser des locutions latines
alors même que
on ne parle pas latin les expressions
s'il n'y a pas mal d'expression que l'on
peut trouver qu'on peut considérer comme
étant bizarre un endroit autant que
faire se peut soit dit en passant l'a
récemment dans une discussion un
collègue a réussi à placer en tout
rectitude
personne n'a compris on mais on a tous
applaudi on était d'accord
alors quand on mélange un peu tout ça le
résultat peut paraître un peu étrange il
faut l'avouer par exemple si on souhaite
demander la copie du jugement justement
pour récupérer une créance c'est comme
ça que ça se passe
on peut formuler sa de la manière
suivante soit il possible autant que
faire se peut afin de recouvrer la
créance d'aller chercher la grosse en
tout rectitude alors vous aurez remarqué
qu'en toute latitude c'est un petit peu
c'est le joker on l'emploie un petit peu
vu qu'on connaît pas trop le sens ce
n'est pour tous même vous dans la vie de
tous les jours pour aller chercher le
pain bonjour je voudrais de baguette de
croissants tout rectitude
bref alors là évidemment vocabulaire à
ce que explication est ce qu'il ya une
raison historique sémantique un
véritable sens à traverser cette
terminologie là et ces expressions ou
est ce que c'est on va dire les reliques
de
le langage unis d'ailleurs peut-être je
vous laisse choisir alors autres autre
idée reçue également c'est pas une idée
reçue c'est un constat ne fait que les
juristes s'habille parfois bizarrement
alors j'imagine que vous avez en tête
peut-être ça ça forcément c'est
surprenant
les amateurs de game of thrones auront
remarqué le petit clin d'oeil à la
famille stark
alors les juristes il s'habille
également comme ça alors il faut savoir
qu'ici on en présence de ce qu'on
appelle les robes de gens de justice
ce sont des robes qui sont utilisés soit
à l'occasion de cérémonies soit lors
d'une audience comme comme la robe
d'avocat mais il faut avouer quand même
que la plupart du temps les juristes
n'ont pas une apparence coup décontracté
il faut le dire un peu part du jury
s'habiller quand même un manière assez
strict sans véritable touche
d'originalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai envie
moi d'aujourd'hui de casser un petit peu
cette image et de vous montrer que le
juriste
le juriste est capable d'une touche
d'originalité ce qui me permettra par la
même occasion de révéler peut-être la
vraie nature des juristes que nous
sommes
[Applaudissements]
est ce qui permet également de contester
une remarque nous critiquer qui est fait
à l'encontre des juristes comme quoi le
juriste serait prétentieux
nous ne sommes pas prétentieux nous
avons véritablement pour mission de
sauver le monde
en fait tu pas très à l'aise
ma carrière est foutue à partir
d'aujourd'hui je veux dire bref alors je
ne sais pas si je serai parvenu à
démontrer que le juriste est un être
humain comme les autres mais je pense
avoir prouvé que nous avions tout de
même un peu d'humour merci
[Applaudissements]